[Music]
now
let's see
hello
all of us
the world has a way of changing
and we change too i know some people
there are moments that separate us
but we always come back together
we heard y'all needed a little love out
here
y'all ever thought about the wild
missions we've been on we've taken out
planes
trains tanks i'm not going to think
about the submarine
[Music]
and now we got cars flying in the air
[Music]
who is he jacob is
dom's brother
been a long time dog little brother
you always say never turn your back on
family but you turned your back on me
now your little family is in my world
whatever's on is you ready it's someone
else
he's got his own private army we need
help
no way
[Music]
so how do y'all want to play this fast
okay this is a bad time to mention this
but i don't drive
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
it's good to be back
hold on
that's been my entire life in your
shadow
and now
you spend the rest of yours
you acting like we on our way to home
depot
i don't wanna die
[Music]
you